advertising used to be simple if a soap
maker wanted some more soap he hired
someone to make a commercial and then
paid a television station to air it on
the soap maker hoped to the people who
saw the commercial bought more soap then
came the Internet it promised technology
that would turn advertising into a
data-driven science the soap maker can
now buy thousands of spots strictly
targeting the very people who are most
likely to buy soap at exactly the moment
when they need that soap the Internet
could finally make advertising efficient
oh man I need some soap and on the
surface this plan seems to be working
this year an estimated seven point eight
billion dollars will be spent on web
video ads in the US for example imagine
a 15-second commercial for soap that
plays before a funny cat video here's
how that ad gets there the soap makers
advertising order goes to a high-tech
exchange where algorithms find websites
that will reach likely soap buyers say a
site with a video of a cat in a bathtub
the more views the video gets presumably
the more people would buy soap except
that's not always the case
many of the ads that the soap maker pays
to play at the start of a video aren't
seen by real people at all you see
sometimes the web site that hosts the
cat video will pay a company to boost
the number of views they get those views
can be legitimate actual people watching
the cat video and the soap ad before but
other times the views can come from
so-called BOTS a body is a computer that
has been hijacked by malware to visit a
particular site on its own even when
there's no human operating by one
estimate more than half of all purchased
traffic is made up of bots to the soap
maker that the bots might seem like real
people watching his ad wonderful but
their faith last year a study found that
11% of display ads and nearly a quarter
of the pricier video ads on the web were
served to bots
and here's the kicker most websites pay
for traffic in some way views the
currency of the Internet can be worth a
lot of money fifty thousand views from a
bot might cost only fifty dollars but
they can fetch advertising revenue with
five hundred dollars or more it is a
slippery business indeed